premier ministre la parole est à
monsieur christian kert merci merci
monsieur le président la question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre de
l'intérieur monsieur le ministre
hier jour de fête nationale dans les
bouches du rhône ain inquiétante
incendie s'est déclaré au coeur du site
industriel de berre site classé seveso
ou deux cuves éloigné de près de 500
mètres l'une de l'autre ont pris feu
quasiment simultanément les premières
investigations montrent que la
probabilité de l'accident est faible un
acte intentionnel ne fait quasiment
aucun doute je relève d'ailleurs en
notre nom collectif la rapidité et
l'efficacité de l'intervention des
services incendie et de sécurité
mobilisés en cette circonstance alors
devant sète ce caractère simultané
comment ne pas imaginer monsieur le
ministre
quelques jours seulement après leur
incroyable vol d'explosifs sur le site
militaire de mihama situé seulement à
une vingtaine de kilomètres de là l'idée
d'un lien avec l'incendié survenu à
berre celle ihome d'alba zèle surtout
lorsque l'on sait que cette
multinationale bat pavillon américain
malveillance coïncidence défaut de
surveillance oui monsieur le ministre se
pose la question de la surveillance de
ces sites on en dénombre près de 1200
sur notre territoire et tous ne sont pas
protégés correctement même lorsqu'ils
sont classés en seuil haut comme celui
de l'étang de berre pas question
monsieur le ministre de polémiquer mais
quand même vous faire part de notre
inquiétude notamment sur ses zones
géographiques ma question est simple
quel directive entendez-vous j'allais
dire enfin havrais s'est non seulement
aux services de l'état mais également
aux sociétés exposées à des risques
particuliers afin que l'on puisse
arriver enrayer ce processus
inquiétant merci si la parole est à
monsieur bernard cazeneuve min
dans l'intérieur ce le député vous avez
dans votre question rappeler les faits
qui sont produits hier deux cuves dans
un site pétrochimique à l'étang de berre
qui prennent feu après une explosion des
services d'incendié et de secours qui
interviennent dans des délais
extrêmement bref avec un déploiement
humains et techniques importants près de
120 sapeurs-pompiers qui ont été sur 6
très rapidement et qui ont réussi dans
un laps de temps bref à contenir
l'incendié et à éviter tous les risques
de pollution
est ce que ces événements sont des
événements qui résulte d'un acte
criminel
il ya une enquête en cours mais les
premiers éléments qui sont communiqués
montrent qu'il s'agit effectivement d'un
acte criminel dont la motivation n'est
pas établi le procureur de la république
d'aix en provence qui a l'autorité de l'
enquête sera menée dans les heures qui
viennent à s'exprimer sur la base des
premiers éléments récupérés par
notamment la gendarmerie nationale et
ses instituts spécialisés qui conduisent
actuellement des opérations de police
scientifique et technique
quelles mesures ont été prises vous dit
prenez des mesures enfin mais nous avons
pris des mesures depuis longtemps dès la
mise en place du plan vigipirate sous
l'autorité du secrétaire général de la
défense nationale par la mobilisation du
ministère de madame ségolène royal des
mesures ont été prises qui mobilise
d'abord les industriels ils ont une
responsabilité particulière du fait des
textes pour la surveillance et la
sécurité des sites industriels les
préfets eux mêmes ont été chargés par
mes soins de contrôler le respect par
les autorités industriels de leurs
obligations et g2 nouveau hier demandé à
ce que ce contrôle soit systématiques
continues compte tenu du niveau du
risque et la ministre ségolène royal
recevra vendredi l'ensemble des
industriels des sites concernés de
manière à rappeler ces règles de façon
extrêmement précise et rigoureuse merci